here's a nice geometry problem ABCD is a
rectangle DCF is equilateral and BCE is
equilateral prove that AEF is also
equilateral
so here's one way to do it drop in
altitude from F and drop an altitude
from E let half of one side be equal to
X and let half to the other side be
equal to Y so DF is equal to 2x the
shorter side is X and the altitude is X
or three and the other equilateral
triangle the side is 2y half the side is
y and this will be y root 3. so
construct this right triangle on this
corner we can calculate its Dimensions
construct this right triangle we
calculate its dimensions and construct
this right triangle calculate its
dimensions so now AE squared can be
calculated a f squared can be calculated
and e f squared can be calculated it
turns out all three of these are equal
to each other and therefore AE equals AF
equals EF so we have an equilateral
triangle a e f